Classical conditioning involves our reflexive responses, such as salivation,
eye blink, and startle responses. Unconditioned stimuli automatically elicit
unconditioned responses. After pairing a neutral stimulus with an unconditioned
stimulus, classical conditioning occurs. And the neutral stimulus becomes a
conditioned stimulus that elicits a conditioned response. Remember Pavlov and
his dogs. Operant conditioning was described by BF Skinner. And he said that we
operate on our environment, and behaviors are selected due to their
consequences. Positive and negative reinforcement produce an increase in a
future frequency of a behavior. Where as positive and negative punishment
produce a decrease in the future frequency of a behavior. Unconditioned
reinforces like food, sex and water, and unconditioned punishers like pain are
effective with no prior learning history. However, condition reinforcers like
money or grades, and condition punishers, like harsh words, are effective
because of a pairing process. Social learning involves learning by watching the
consequences of somebody else's behavior. If we see somebody being rewarded for
doing something, we be more likely to do that as well if we want to be
rewarded. Also the same is true for consequences that are negative. Remember
the Bobo of our experiments, these are examples of social learning. Our
learning is a function of all these processes. Classical conditioning, operant
conditioning, and social learning